this is what I absolutely love about
Trump
he will come down and he will help all
of these desperate people and He will
slap his name on the water bottle yeah
really well to be fair this is what
really annoyed me during the Trump
Administration among many other things
they would mock Trump over Trump water
Trump magazine and Trump's stake and
what they wouldn't tell you is that this
was these were brand products for his
Golf Resorts yep so when you go to
Walmart and they've got the Walmart
brand it's good great value or whatever
when you go to a grocery store and they
have their name there that's all it is
they were acting like Trump was selling
Trump water in grocery stores so I went
to Trump Doral once
and they were all to all the Liberals
were like Trump water went out of
business and Trump magazine is gone I
walk in I walk in the hotel room and I
look down at the table and this Trump
magazine a bottle of trump water and I'm
like what are these people talking about
these are companies that Donald Trump
owns that provide these materials to his
Resorts so Trump has a bunch of these
water bottles probably from a bunch of
different Resort properties and he said
grab what we got ship it out